[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have officially
revealed the PS plus offerings for
essential subscribers for the month of
February 2023. the following games can
be downloaded from Tuesday the 7th of
February there's four games in total
this time so let's do this Ollie Ollie
World kicks off the month a 2.5 D skater
that combines speed timing and a
challenging trick system and the visuals
you're seeing right now don't do it
justice the basic premise is getting
from A to B but how you get there
matters while a novice is learning how
to kickflip and Ollie an accomplished
player is attempting to get through each
stage in a single never-ending combo The
Adventure Time looking world we are in
is named radlandia and unlike other olly
olly games this world has other
characters inhabiting it and we can talk
to them this ragtag crew give additional
challenges and unlock the world with you
there is a high skill ceiling to the
game if you put enough time in but also
it's easy enough that beginners will
complete the campaign the insta fails
from Landing your board slightly
incorrect are gone from the series
making this game more inviting and more
forgiving to new players oh and
character customization is here too and
it has a crazy amount of depth oleoli's
Metacritic score is 84 out of 100 making
it a great game take a look see at Mafia
Definitive Edition back in 2002 Mafia
released on the PS2 an open world action
game it was held in high esteem so
naturally it was given an upgrade 20
years later we play as Tommy a cab
driver who has a chance encounter with a
mobster and somehow finds himself inside
that criminal family warring to stay in
control of 1930s Chicago or lost Heaven
as it's called in-game the story is
compelling and they've taken the time to
update the script to evolve characters
and amplify their traits people who
enjoy gangster movies will enjoy this
game playing through tense gunfights
surviving insane races and escaping the
lore when things go wrong that said the
gameplay does feel like a PS2 game
regularly the open world is plentiful
but there's nothing really to do outside
of the campaign and the Gunplay and
general movement does feel like a 20
year old game so don't go in thinking
this is 1930s GTA it simply doesn't have
that depth but it has a story and a
setting worthy of your time over 20
linear missions Metacritic score 76 so
it's good nothing says February like a
horror game Evil Dead the game an
asymmetric multiplayer game we are
tasked with surviving the night as a
small group of characters from the
movies including many versions of Ash
Williams as a team we collect pages of
the Necronomicon and other artifacts to
secure Victory by casting a spell and
sending the demons back home meanwhile a
lone player becomes that demon and their
task is simple take out all the
survivors before they cast that spell
the demon can summon minions set traps
and possess life forms while the heroes
have melee and Firearms to fend off the
attackers the gameplay has much more
depth than that with dedicated skill
trees and different Survivor classes
with friends in a voice chat evil said
the game can be a great deal of fun but
there are definitely many clunky and
frustrating moments you have to play
through but this is a good game the
critics say it's a 72 out of 100 and
wait there's an extra
ticket month as you know Destiny 2
became a free to play game and made
money by offering paid DLCs as the
latest upgrade arrives in February PS
plus are giving us the Beyond Light DLC
as an extra in about five hours the
campaign is complete telling the story
of Kel Aramis who has found a way to
harness the darkness on the Frozen moon
of Jupiter known as Europa as we battle
her and her Fallen minions we are
granted that power known as stasis an
iced based set of abilities and special
moves which vary between Hunter Warlock
and Titan classes when the campaign ends
the grind begins replaying activities to
obtain better loot a note to make is
that late in February a new update to
the game will drop which changes many
systems within Destiny 2. so you may
want to wait for that to drop Metacritic
score 76 another good game so that's how
a month I'm Adam you're awesome it's
been a pleasure see you next time